hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you
i want to read gavin newsom now you
write about this too newsome and
desantis i feel like florida
and
california crystallize the two sides of
america and and man it's so interesting
republicans freedom was like always
their brand but now
you know abortion rights taking away a
freedom
it's kind of a new ball game with that
so this is an ad that our governor gavin
newsom ran in florida he said freedom is
under attack in your state this is this
is gavin ism of california addressing
the
florida voters your republican leaders
they're banning books making it harder
to vote restricting speech in classrooms
even criminalizing women i urge all
florida to join the fight join us in
california we still believe in freedom
this is so opposite of what they used to
do freedom of speech freedom to choose
freedom from hate freedom to love
don't let them take your freedom
so i guess my question is who's got the
freedom fight now because i could see
the republicans saying well we stand up
for your right to have your guns we
don't covet [ __ ] mandates you know
you have your freedom to be free
i certainly don't always feel free in
this state i must say and i have felt
freer in florida but who wins the
freedom battle right now what do you
think well first of all i'm kind of an
old-school liberal so
i think if you don't believe in freedom
for the people you really dislike you
probably don't believe in it at all
[Applause]
and both parties have been have been bad
about that in uh in recent election
cycles and and uh you know you see the
you see this with the very very
restrictive republican laws that are
being passed you had a north carolina
bill that would have required people to
report kids for showing signs of gender
non-conformity i mean that's that's a
really scary bill right but then on the
democratic side you have all this
internet censorship the state of
california has 396 000 regulations which
is a hundred thousand more than any
other state
so i don't think i don't think either
party has a particular like stranglehold
on freedom i think they're they're both
weak on this issue
and this is where i disagree i do think
that the democrats will go into november
as the party of freedom
because democrats are standing up for
the freedom of women to make their own
health care decisions
the
the freedom of people the freedom of
people to marry who they love
um and the freedom
to know that they can send their kids to
school without the fear of them being
shot up
and um and and and and and and to your
point and just to your point about about
the gop argument about freedom is they
were like oh my god big government
they're making us wear mass oh the
temerity all this
the people who said okay we want small
government now they want to make the
most private health care decisions for
women they want to put mike pence in the
obgyn exam room with women when their
feet aren't stirred i'm glad
and we're all against that